this is the story of Peter Pan.
Peter Pan is a magical boy.
"Pan" means "God of all", approximately.
and it is no coincidence that it is called "Pan".
and he is a boy who does not want to grow up and is magical.
That's because children are magical.
they can be anything. There is nothing but potential.
And Peter Pan doesn't want to lose it. Why?
Well ... he's got a couple of adults around him,
but the main adult is Captain Hook.
And who the hell wants to grow into Captain Hook?
First ... you have a hook,
secondly, you are a tyrant,
and thirdly: you are being persecuted by a dragon of chaos with an alarm in your stomach.
Crocodile ... already has your part.
Well ... that's what happens when you get older: time will have your part.
Has a taste for you ...
and eventually devour you.
And so ... The hook is so traumatic that there can be nothing but a tyrant.
And then Peter Pan looks at the traumatized Hook
and says: No, I do not sacrifice my childhood for something like that.
That's fine ... except that he ends up being the king of the lost boys in Nezemi Earth.
Well, it doesn't exist and who the hell wants to be the king of the lost boys?
And he also sacrifices the opportunity to have a real relationship with a woman - Wendy.
She's a rather conservative, middle-class girl from London.
He wants to grow up, have children and have a life.
He accepts his mortality, accepts his maturity.
Peter Pan has to settle for the fairy Zvonilka
She doesn't even exist. She's kind of ...
She's something of a fairy pornography.
It does not exist.
She's a replacement for the real thing.
But the dichotomy you're talking about is very tricky,
because sacrifice is part of adolescence.
You have to sacrifice
the pure potential of childhood
in exchange for a real structure.
And why would you do that?
Well ... one reason may be: It will happen to you whether you do it or not.
Either you choose your damn restriction ...
or you get caught off guard when you're 30.
Or - worse - when you're 40.
and then ... not a happy day.
I see such people and it seems to me more and more often in our culture,
because people can postpone their maturity without having to pay for it immediately.
but the "debt" will accumulate.
and when it comes to you, it will beat you,
because when you're 25, you can be an idiot, no problem.
even if you're looking for a job
you have no experience and you are pretty clueless ...
yeah, you're still young, no problem.
These are young people - they are full of potential.
Okay ... now you're the same person at age thirty.
People are not so excited about you at the moment.
What the hell have you been doing for the last 10 years?
Well ... I'm just as clueless as when I was 22.
Yeah ... but you're not 22 anymore.
You're an old child.
And that's an ugly thing ... old child.
a partial reason why you choose your damn victim ...
because the sacrifice is inevitable
but at least you choose it.
and then there's something even more complicated in a sense ...
The problem is, if you're a child, you're just a potential.
And very vague. You can be anything ... but you are nothing.
But you're going to learn something.
and then at least you become something.
And when you are something, it reopens the world to you.
If you're a really good plumber,
then you are much more than just a plumber. You will become a good employer ...
I don't want to humiliate plumbers ... all the honor of plumbers.
They saved more lives than doctors.
Hygiene.
If you are a really good plumber, you have employees, you run a business,
you teach other people, enrich their lives,
You are a community pillar, you have a family.
Once you get through this narrow learning period,
which restricts and limits you while developing
You can go to the other side with many new opportunities.
and Jung talked about it, he thought ...
part of the good development in the second half of life
is the rediscovery of the child
you left when you were learning.
So you are someone and you get the potential again.
Very, very clever ... Well, he was very, very smart.
It's very wise.
Very wise to know about it.
Sacrifice.
We'll also talk about that.
You can choose your damn victim.
That is all. You can't choose any.
You sacrifice yourself, whether you like it or not.
That's good to know.
although ...
it's hard to realize it.
More questions?
"I have one."
"You've noticed that people are hanging out until they're 20 ..."
"Where does it come from ... from the culture we live in?"
I think universities are helping.
Because you can go to university to be nothing.
Instead of going to university to become someone.
It's the Island of Pleasure.
And the price you pay for it, especially in the States, is debt.
And you're haunted because the university can rob you.
So they rob your future self while allowing you to pretend you have an identity.
Very ugly.
And you can't report bankruptcy on your student loan in the United States.
it is a contractual serfdom.
And that's exactly Island of Pleasure ... exactly that.
And tuition is extremely exorbitant.
And a partial reason why universities do not put much pressure on students
and let them do many things,
basically ... why the hell would you drive them away?
These are hundreds of thousands of dollars or more.
So they can do what they want ...
if you can sell them to salt mines.
So.
It's not the only reason, because the next thing is,
the speed of technological change is now so great, and the amount of turnover ...
It's really harder for people who are, say, 18-20 years old ...
When I was a kid, more or less ...
This difficult period of life was between 14 and 17 years. Somehow.
Now I mean 18-25 years. Somehow.
And I think the reason for this is ...
that all the work that the damned hippies complained about
that they were sentenced to them in the 1960s, disappeared.
Their problem was: Oh God, I have to go to work for the corporation
and get a salary for the rest of your life.
And I will have a pension and it will be my whole life.
It seems to me that this is a much better offer than ...
an endless series of part-time jobs at Starbucks.
So ... partly it is
Now we have space in our culture
missing people who change from children to adults.
And the price we pay for it is postponed later.
And that's not a good thing ... it's not a good thing.